someone shot me a periscope of a vine of
a snapchat of a screengrab over text did
say they saw Cindy pee in the shower you
hear that your girl like them go to
shower I wonder if she must sharks in
the back of the toilet too you already
know them Germans is on that
y'all need to okay that Cindy's a
classy lady and my future baby mama
sounds like to me
oh it's a Bill Cosby sexting oh
I seen he finally hit me back she
must want to get wife Doug say what
money I mean she must want to have her
cake speed with no emotional connection
damn I can't find a sex tape I got it
but it ain't plain what the is a
buffer
who do thanks Obama goddamnit Cosby what
the man oh I'm gonna go home
and watch the region whoa what ain't
getting no daddy now me neither
damn Huxtable roofied the whole internet
I gotta go see what Cindy was texting me
about uh-huh where you going to the
library my nigs I know they got Wi-Fi
what's a library it's where homeless
people chill with Starbucks is closed